[Music]
hello everyone
uh having done with the kinematical
hypothesis discussion in the previous
video let us now proceed
through the application of the virtual
work equation uh towards the first steps
that lead finally to the governing
equations and boundary conditions
within the context of the purple bond
common plate equations
all right so uh before you even
do that uh let me just re-emphasize
that uh just like in the classical plate
theory
we are going to forcibly assume
that sigma zz
is equal to zero now on to the
application
of
the virtual work equation so
as we have seen it a number of times
earlier we are going to write down
the the general expression in this form
and even though you may be
accepting at least this equation at face
value but let me just point out that
there is a little bit of a subtle issue
present here also because in the left
hand side you have this term uh
this this non-linear strain
but this kind of stress that we are
writing
this strictly speaking uh
there is a little bit of a problem here
because uh what we should be writing
is something which would be conjugate
to this strain so when we were dealing
uh strictly within the scope of the
small deformation theory when this was
not e the non-linear strain rather the
epsilon
then writing this as the sigma
the sigma that we're all familiar with
the stress components
that was fine but
uh it is as if now we are dealing with
it
in a hybrid fashion so in the strains we
are dealing it
uh we are writing it like the nonlinear
strains
but here we are writing it up the same
stress that we bet
are writing earlier okay so this is not
really speaking the conjugate of this
strain
uh the stress is not the conjugate of
this string but anyway
uh this is this is another bitter pill
that we have to solve
uh and will not uh will not delve too
much into into that detail
anyway so
uh what we'll do is we'll deal with the
left hand side
and if you thought that the derivation
of the classical plate theory was long
wait till you see the the length of this
derivation
okay so uh this
is indeed going to be a little bit of a
test of patience
but we will persist through it so
we start out like this
and then of course we we write out all
the
terms
and please note that we are going to
have two contributions
uh one from the sigma x y and one from
the sigma y
x but they are the same
so we end up with twice of sigma xy
delta e xy please note here
that there is no other contribution from
any of the other terms first
because the sigma zz has been already
forcibly assumed to be zero so even
though
as we had mentioned in the previous
video the e z by itself is not zero
because but because of the forcible
assumption of the sigma z to be zero
that
uh the next term sigma z delta e z
uh that does not and that is basically
zero next for the sigma y z del e y z we
have seen that
via our uh hypothesis
the e y z is approximately zero and so
also
the e zx is zero so the final term is
also zero so these are the only terms
which are not zero
at the level of approximation that we
are allowing ourselves within the
context of this
purple one common light equations all
right
[Music]
next we are going to
expand it even further
so sigma xx this e x x is now
uh written in the form e
x x naught you remember this e x x
naught from the previous
video uh minus
z d squared del square w del x square
so if you don't remember this i
sincerely urge you to go back to the
previous video
and take a look at how exx turned out to
be
this particular form
next
all right now
please note that
this entire volume integral that i am
going to
subdivide into an integration
with respect to z
and when i write this
you please note that
i am again considering the
the kind of plate that we had been
considering
back in our plate theory so even though
i'm not drawing it you can refer back to
that geometry
uh it is exactly the same kind of
geometry that i'm referring to here also
so this first integration is with
respect to z the next one
is over the entire lateral domain
[Music]
which is uh in the xy plane
so the next integration is with respect
to a
all right so
what we are going to do now is
to consider uh
terms which are independent of
z so you understand that this term is
independent of z
this term is independent of z and this
term is independent of z
okay we are not going to worry too much
about the
what is uh what is dependent
or not dependent on z within this sigma
xx within the sigma yy and the sigma xy
uh because of course uh i mean even from
our
previous studies we know that they do
have a distribution over the
over the thickness so what we'll do is
we'll we'll capture that entire thing
will capture that entire
integration of the sigma xx
uh so so you just focus on this term uh
the rest of the
two terms will be exactly the same so if
we consider this particular terms
integration minus h by 2 to h by 2 sigma
x x
delta e x x naught okay just this
particular product
then when we do the integration with
respect to
z this delta e x x naught
that can very much come out of the
integration with respect to z
so all that will be left with is
integration minus h by 2 to h by 2
sigma x x dz and that particular
integration with respect to z we will
over the sigma x xx that we are going to
represent by
nx okay
so you're left with this similarly
we consider this term so
what we'll be left with is an
integration with respect to z
of the sigma yy and that we will refer
to
as ny that is multiplied of course
by this delta e y y naught
next for this uh
now we will again be left with this
integration
minus h by 2 to h by 2 sigma x y d z
and that we will refer to as n x y
so we'll have twice and x y
delta
[Music]
e x y naught
so this integration is with respect to
a the area over the lateral dimensions
next let us consider the dependence
uh or the terms which now which had this
z dependence like this so now
when we have this integration of it'll
it'll be left with
integration minus h by 2 to h by 2 sigma
x x
but this time multiplied by this z and
this
del square w del x square that can come
out of the integration with respect to z
so what we'll be left with is
a term of
which will be like sigma xx z within the
integrand and that we will refer to as
m x so this is uh something which we
have
uh already seen uh
in our classical plate theory
and please note that see the presence
of this minus there will be minus here
because the presence of this so
so we are collecting all these negative
signs present in the three terms
together
in exactly the same fashion from this
one we are going to have
my but before that this mx it is
multiplied by this del square w del x
square we should not forget that
[Music]
so from here we are going to obtain a
m y multiplied with del square w
del y square and finally from this term
we are going to obtain it twice
m x y del square w
del x del y this entire integration
is with respect to a
all right so what we're going to say is
that
this entire first integration
that will refer to as
the first term on the lhs remember that
we are only dealing with the left hand
side now
and this term so
what i'll do is i'll absorb this minus
within it okay
so let me absorb the minus within it so
later on i don't forget it
it's something like this with a minus in
front
so this entire thing
that will be the second term on the lhs
so first i'll deal with this lhs1
okay these these terms we have already
dealt with
i mean uh terms which is similar to this
uh back in classical plate theory
uh so let me see what what is uh the new
thing going on here
in this lhs1 all right
so i'll just copy this thing out
and go to the next page
so this is our lhs one
all right so
uh this is the um this is the part where
we
cannot escape but do have to substitute
the expression for this e x x naught the
e y y naught
and e x y naught okay there is no escape
from this and this is where things will
become
quite lengthy
so we have to be a little bit patient
here so nx
uh this e x x naught
that is
so let's take a look
[Music]
so we have this we can copy it from here
and place it just for a quick reference
uh in fact we can copy all of these
quick reference
so just keeping that as uh as a
reference
so these are the kind of things that i
could not have been able to do on him on
a chalkboard
all right so now when we when we take
the first variation of this
now what i obtain is
del uh delta u s
del x plus
del w del x del
delta w del x
next n y multiplied by
del delta
v s del y
plus del w del y
del delta w del y
and next
twice and xy
well uh i'll have to adjust this
okay so i'll have
del delta us
del y plus del
uh delta ps
del x
plus
um so i'll have to use it
part by part del w del x
del delta w del y
plus
del w del y del
delta w del
x
okay so this entire thing
is an integration with respect to a
so i'll just adjust this entire thing
okay
[Music]
now
i'll have to collect the terms somewhat
strategically here
[Music]
see these are the kind of things where
a symbolic python can be helpful helpful
uh could have been helpful but only in
parts okay so
the strategic decisions about which
terms to consider
where that is something which um
only an intelligent human being can
can take okay so we do have to
you know we do have to proceed in a
somewhat systematic intelligent fashion
here
all right so uh let me consider
uh i i'll break expand these terms
so i'm considering this next this
[Music]
next i'll consider these two turns um
[Music]
however please note that this e x y
naught it does have a
a half also present so i have missed
that half here me just correct that
so this half is going to cancel with
this twice
and i'll end up with
an xy
del delta u s
del y
plus n x y del
delta v s del x
[Music]
next up
i will have this term
with the del delta w del x
but you please note that i will also
have
another term involving the del delta w
del x from here
so what i want to do is to club those
two together
so n x
del w del x let me do one thing let me
just
put a tick mark on all the terms that i
have already taken care of
so this is taken care of this is taking
care of
this and this has also been taken care
of
n x delta w del x so that has been taken
care of just now
plus an x y this n x y multiplied by
this
del w del y
this and that thing is multiplied by del
delta w del x
so what i've just done is to take care
of this term
and this term and finally
what i'll have is
this term over here
plus n y
del w del y
plus n x
y del w del x
so this term multiplied by
del delta w del y
this is an integration again with
respect to
a and now
we have taken care of all the terms from
the previous step
okay so what we do next
is something which we have done
back in our
you know classical plate theory also
but you note
that first of all we are only
considering the left hand side
and here on this page we are only
considering
the first part of that lhs and within
that
it is already becoming so lengthy so the
next next line that i'm going to write
that is going to be really really
lengthy okay uh but we'll forge ahead
okay uh so it's like this
i think it'll be it'll be little bit
better
if i actually go to the next page for
this
i will have a little bit more real
estate to
write out the terms
okay
so what i want to do now is to proceed
towards
a step uh where i would be left
with uh this first variation of the us
vs and the w without the presence of
these partial derivatives okay i want to
get rid of this partial derivative so
exactly in the same fashion that i have
proceeded in the classical plate theory
what i'll do is uh i'll
rewrite the terms in this fashion
so this one i'll write like an
x delta u s
and of course i'll have to compensate
for the extra term that i have
introduced
[Music]
in this fashion next for this term
i'll have del
l y n y delta v
s minus
del n y del y delta v s
next for this i'll again have in a
similar fashion
del y and x y
delta u s minus
del n x y
del y delta u s
for this one i'll have
del del x and
x y delta v
s minus del
del x and x y
sorry about that
delta vs
and now uh for this and that thing
i'll take the del del x of this entire
thing okay
so
del del x of
[Music]
an x del w del x
plus n x y del w
del y delta w
close curly bracket minus
del del x
of this thing
so this thing
multiplied by delta w
and finally i'll have
from this term
del y
curly bracket
and y del w del y
plus and x y
del w del x
delta w close curly bracket
minus del del y of this entire thing
multiplied by delta w
and i'll have to close the
integration also just make a little
space here
so this entire integration is with
respect to
a all right
that was quite long now uh
this is the part where we really have to
use our brain a little bit
what what we're going to proceed here
with now
is is we want to proceed in a way that
that we can actually use the greens
theorem uh in the same way that we had
done
back in uh in the previous chapter on
the classical plate theory
and please note there that what we had
done
was to consider terms like
del del x of something plus
del del y of something
and then to use the greens theorem to
write this in terms
of the uh the
nxy and the ny uh the normal components
uh to the periphery okay so
the idea is exactly the same it is only
uh
it's only going to be uh
[Music]
it it may appear to be a little bit more
difficult just because we have so many
different terms here
uh but if you can just uh just see
this in the spirit of things that that
we need to do
i mean if you just consider all the del
del x terms
okay so you see what we have here
is this term
involving the del del x we have another
term
involving the delta x here we also have
the delta x here but
but please note that this is not a del
del x over the entire thing
okay so we cannot take that similarly we
cannot take this
there is another term involving the
delta x over the entire thing it is here
[Music]
so these three terms we are going to
consider together
next up
the del del y terms this one
[Music]
this one and
well this one okay
the rest of the terms they do contain
the del del x and the del del y
but they are not over the entire terms
so we leave them as they are
so
[Music]
so if we take this one this one and
this one together up
and this one this one and this one
together
we have this thing del del x of
something plus del del y of something
that uh can be converted to
from this from this area integration to
a cyclic integration over the entire
periphery that's a line integral
basically over the entire periphery it's
a cyclic integral because the periphery
is a closed one of course
and this line integral would be starting
from a certain point and coming back to
the same point
so in that term uh
or in that fashion uh what we are going
to do is
uh
so it's something like this let me see
if i can try to make this uh
make this somewhat visually more
appealing
so we have this sorry about that
so we have this sort of a combination
and what we are doing here is
uh we think that
this is the white these are the white
terms and these are the orange colored
terms so you see i've just clubbed them
together
kind of okay and these orange colored
terms also they are
clubbed here so what we are going to do
is to and this thing is over the entire
area okay so this thing
[Music]
can be written as
this where these are
the terms which are underlined by white
and this would be multiplied by nx
this would be of course a line integral
over then that periphery
plus all the terms
in orange underlying by orange
and that multiplied that will be
multiplied by n y
and this integration will be with
respect
to the variable s which tracks the
entire periphery
of the plate okay so if what i just
discussed
it seems a little alien to you i
strongly suggest
that you go and revise what was
discussed in the previous chapter on
classical play theory so in terms of the
mathematical idea
there is absolutely no difference it is
just that we have more number of terms
present here okay now subsequent to that
what we had done was to actually use the
fact
that an x is equal to
d y d s we have also
uh discussed this in detail uh
in a in a in
a video in a lecture video in the
previous chapter
so i'm not going to go into the details
of this
so sorry about that this should be ny
so what i'm going to do is substitute
this n x by this
d y d s and this n y by this minus d x d
s and you see that this d s and this d
is this d s and this d s they are going
to cancel
so ultimately what we're going to left
with is
this thing
the y minus
dx all right
and let us not forget that these are all
the terms underlined by
white and these are all the terms
underlined by orange
okay so
so let me just write down those terms
i almost want to end this video here
because it's already quite long
but let me not just break the continuity
and let me just write down those terms
okay
so
i have to go to the next page now um
let me copy this entire thing
and in order to save some space
i will make this a little bit smaller
so i'm just keeping this for the sake of
reference
okay i think that should do
so the first term i'm considering the
the terms underlined in white
so what i have is nx
delta us so all the terms within the
bracket
that are that are underlined by white
next delta us
plus and xy delta
vs plus
and x delta w del x
plus n x y
till w del y
multiplied by delta w so this entire
thing
[Music]
that will be this sort of a line
integral
next with a minus sign because
you see when we go over to a version
involving the nx
and the ny which are the normal
components
of the x and y components of the normal
to the periphery
they do involve this plus but when we go
over to this version involving the d y
and the dx
curve see the presence or the expression
of this ny involving the minus sign
this becomes a minus so
here it is a minus
so now we are going to consider the
terms which are present within the
brackets
of these terms underlined by orange so
we have n y delta v s
plus n x y
delta u s
and this term here plus
n y del w del y
plus n x y del w
del x delta w
so this is uh with respect to
x and we should not forget that these
terms are also very much
present okay this terms involving the
on these other terms which are not
underlined okay
so uh we have
del tan nx del x
plus del n x y
del y
[Music]
so
this is with the delta us
next we have
this term and this term
del n y l y
plus del in x y
del x
delta vs so
we have taken care of this one we have
taken care of
this one then this one and this one so
all that is left with this
are this and this so
[Music]
minus delta x
and x del w del x
plus n x y
del w del y
plus del l
y i think i'll just take these terms
downstairs
and y del w del y
plus n x y
del w del x
this entire thing has as its coefficient
delta w so basically i have taken care
of this term and this term so all the
terms are covered now
uh of course i have to close the
integrations
[Music]
[Music]
okay so i do have
this thing missing over here
all right now
you see
we are uh so to speak in a situation
which was
which is quite similar uh to
what we had obtained in the classical
plate theory but back then
uh we were dealing with terms involving
the
uh mx m y and m x y
and please note here also we do have
those terms
but they are present in the second part
of the lhs
okay so we do have the presence of the
mx mx y and m x y
but then the second part of the lhs so
what we have done basically through this
rather laborious um
and lengthy derivation is to just take
care of the first part of the ls
lhs okay so we are at a at the stage
where we
want to be now but we also have to take
care of the
uh of the second part of the lhs and
only then we can um go forward
uh to the to obtaining the governing
equations but there will be
many steps to it okay now uh
i i won't continue this already long
video anymore
uh what i will do is uh
i'll just leave it here and then in the
next video
i'll take care of the second part of the
ledges and and then
uh and maybe again not repeat the same
kind of lengthy derivations
uh but the
important thing would be to uh to
actually utilize
the the things which are present here to
kind of simplify
what we ultimately obtain because what
we ultimately open is
going to be quite lengthy if you can
imagine that okay so
uh at this point
uh i think it is best if i just uh if i
just break this video here
uh and then continue with the second
part of the letters in the next video
all right thank you very much
[Music]
sorry there's a small correction here uh
when i close this
integration uh i'm taking basically
taking this minus sign out so this will
be a plus here
and this will be a plus here all right